[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم معزوني محمد 44 سنه باش ندخلكم
في عالمي اللي هو عالم الليغو مش كان
الصغار يبدا معنا واحنا صغار وبعد بشكل
[موسيقى]
تتكلف برشا فلوس
هديك شحنه تعدينا
للفري
كيفاش نتبادلوا مع بعضنا
القطعه
موجوده ونخرج
[موسيقى]
غرام من برشا حكاية
الحكايه الداخليني
مليانه صغير ممكن عمري عشر سنين
وانا عمري عشر سنين
صندوق هذا
المفتاح
وصندوقين
وعمله تونسيه واجنبيه اثنين
[موسيقى]
مليون
هذه
كوبا
هذه غينيا غينيا
هذه غنى
تونس عملت لها
هذوكم
بالانواع الحيوانات وحدهم تونس
بالتنبري بالتمرين من اول تمري حتى الاخر
تمبري
بتاعه
ولدك كان صغير عمره عام ونص عامين
نحب ديناصور
ات خرجناهم من البلدان وعملنا الديناصورات
وحدهم
جدور عائليه
والعملات العالميه
تطور
اللي هو
حاجه جديده
والعملات
من جدودنا لاولادنا
[موسيقى]